what's up guys i just listened to joe
biden talk about inflation and boy are
we in trouble first of all he said that
this was his top domestic issue he's
trying to address it he's trying to
figure out how to get inflation down but
obviously he's not a central banker and
he also he ain't in charge of actually
putting forward any sort of actual
legislation to get inflation down that's
the central bank's job and they're doing
the best they can by raising inflation
rates but i don't know what's going to
happen here especially going into
midterm elections but here's a whole
bunch of other stuff that he said listen
to this clip real quick and see word for
word what the president united states
thinks is the solution to inflation
i know the families all across america
are hurting because of inflation i went
i want every american to know that i'm
taking inflation
very seriously and it's my top for
domestic priority there are two
leading causes of inflation we're seeing
today
the first cause of inflation is a once
in a century pandemic
not only did it shut down our global
economy it through the supply chains and
demand completely out of whack a second
cause mr putin's war in ukraine
you saw we saw in march that
60 of inflation that month was due to
price increases at the pump for gasoline
putin's war has raised food prices as
well americans have two potential to
pass forward my plan is the lower
employer and lower every day it costs
for everyday costs for hard work and
americans
and lowered the deficit by asking large
corporations and the wealthiest
americans
to not engage in price gouging and to
pay their fair share in taxes the
republican plan is increased taxes on
the middle class families led
billionaires and large companies off the
hook as they raise profits raise prices
and re-profits of record number
record amounts
and it's really that simple
now i gotta say one of the things that
actually blows my mind is that we're
almost two years into the pandemic and
we're still talking about how the
pandemic is the cause of inflation and
or vladimir putin and his invasion of
ukraine what are we talking about
there's no accountability there is no
responsibility they take for the central
bank or elected officials with all the
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
even if you want to say that there's
broken supply chains or there's some
sort of issue from the pandemic or that
there's some sort of impact from that
russian invasion of ukraine you still
have to say that you had some part you
can't completely absolve yourself and
say that you did nothing wrong then on
top of that to make matters even worse
your plan is to ask corporations not to
price gouge what is going on it feels
like all of the politicians the current
administration they have lost control
they don't have any ability to get
inflation down they're begging the
central bank to go ahead and to address
it and of course you got to get in that
partisan politics anytime that you see
them start talking about the fact that
oh the republicans plan is this or oh
the democrats plan is this what is this
nonsense everyday americans across the
aisle are suffering we have to get
inflation down but asking corporations
to go ahead and not price gouge that
ain't the solution boss we got to have
more rational people trying to actually
address this issue hopefully the central
bank will be successful in their efforts
but if not it's just going to be more
pain ahead for many people now the odds
are that inflation likely did peak
already and of course there's going to
be the base effect from where the prices
started to surge last summer so
naturally the rate of inflation should
come down here but it's still not going
to be enough there's plenty of people
who didn't get an eight and a half nine
percent pay raise they're getting paid
less today than they were two years ago
and that's a big problem if you're
someone in america just trying to make a
living and live a life of freedom
happiness and financial security
we gotta solve inflation and this plan
sounds ridiculous